joining me here for the first time on on
our program is a man who's been in films
like Gran Torino flags of our Father
Invictus and so much more and he is the
co-founder of a new line of clothes
shirts socks hats and accessories for
men and women made exclusively here in
the USA it's called the made here brand
from Scott Eastwood good to see you sir
good to be here you got it
I like this logo here again it's a shot
of hold it up right there that's like
our little Uncle Sam he's like our sexy
Uncle Sam well I mean it's an Uncle Sam
with his hat he's looking down and it
looks like he's had a long night of
partying yeah yeah where the the bowtie
has been undone it's true you know
chardonnays is that a few of chardonnays
yeah he has moderate peninsula roots
well I was saying that you have your guy
I've got my logo
I've got your guy that's me but what is
he running from well he's running - I
was running - running - not his past no
no that's me I run the 40-yard dash at
the NFL Scouting Combine every single
year for charity now I do it and that's
me running and when over five years ago
when we decided to start the show here
Chris Long who is running DirecTV at the
time says how about you running and I
said let's do that
he's showing a prototype and then the
right leg that's up you know we
photoshopped it to look a little bit
more athletic oh we moved we moved the
leg in no it looks good
thanks Scott I appreciate what did you
do the 40 in last year I ran it in six
flat okay now we're showing it on the
screen the gallery mandator to see it
right here there you go okay there you
know it's not easy coming in hot right
there is where my 49 year old groin gave
way right there's rider out there you
did you taunted really pretty and then I
ran it two more times because you know
why I've got grit and determination sir
that's all right I can see that now
Scotty's would I have seen that I have
heard and now I want to see that you
have run a 40-yard dash they met at a
national football league facility of
your own right yes I have
I have done that actually with Kevin
Hart that's a story mm-hmm true story
okay uh what what what gave on this day
no I didn't tear my groans good report
that's my word but we did see photo
pants um with the Rams watch camp he
beat me but I feel like in the long run
I would have smoked him cuz I was just
getting started you know I feel like I
was it was like a horse in the cage and
I didn't get my full that well here's
what you were doing is you were thinking
score yeah you're thinking I've got 90
yards to go exactly that's a long game
you're in for yes you were trying to put
six on the board yeah I understand but
Kevin Hart's a little rangy too right I
mean he's he's cagey he's the wiry
yeah he's wire he's a wiry guy yeah did
you play football yourself I did you did
I did yeah I played football
growing up played you know Pop Warner
played for six seven years it was good
and I like I said I think at some point
yes girls got a little more important
than football yeah okay I choose yeah
those things you know sometimes they're
not mutually exclusive you know like
you're not can have it all look I was
never the star stud of the team and I
think if I was maybe I would have like
leveraged one yet the other what you
play I played everything I played like
defensive end I play cornerback you know
I did a variety of positions okay
yeah and how long did you play into high
school I played up until high school I
played from like Pee Wee's all the way
through and then - hey I don't know if I
have time for this when did you start
acting Scott Eastwood when did that
happen for you
I started professionally doing it yes
the year I started college mm-hmm so was
18 where'd you go to school I went I was
going to Santa Barbara City College of
time then you went to Loyola Marymount
went to Loyola Marymount uh that was
after bouncing around to a few city
colleges sir yeah and yeah I think I got
through about six years okay okay so you
figured that out and then you started
acting
I was I was doing it all through college
action okay I was sort of doing it as I
was going to school okay I was really
going to school to appease my mother she
was like please just get a college
degree and I was like okay so dad wasn't
concerned
well he's not he didn't get in graduate
college and he did pretty good he was
like you need to do this he was sort of
right whatever you want to do just go
and do it right Scott Eastwood here on
the Richardson show and we'll talk about
your made here brand in a second what
was the first time where you realized
that your your dad was pretty famous
when did that first hit you oh that's a
good question I only try to ask those
yeah you know what I mean like I can see
that no I only asked the cream of the
crop you are picking up what I am
putting down is yes obviously but you
have given me from your nadir brand yeah
right here in front of me I think it had
to have been sitting and watching
Unforgiven and then watching I had to
have probably been eight or ten 100 and
forgiving came out in the early 90s and
I watched the Academy Awards that year
where he won the Academy Award for Best
Picture and I think Best Director to
cheese and that's when I really knew
like the like his monumental success
well I got to tell you well it's
interesting you mentioned that movie
yeah I think I mean when I talk about
perfect movies Unforgiven is in my top
five four perfect movies like yeah
getting to end not a frame of it is
imperfect it's all perfect I love that
movie man yeah ya know it's it's it's up
there it's in my it's in my top I'd say
it's in my top three no but I mean I
don't know if it's suitable for an
eight-year-old to be very honest with
you I don't know if I'd be sitting my
eight-year-old write down and like let's
let's talk about lil bill and willing
money and
and and all that stuff I don't I don't
know the point next time look I don't
mean to denigrate no no no the parenting
skills that you've been subject but I
just wonder have to said affecting like
you're very careful with the next words
talking about his parenting skills I'm
feeling lucky to him yeah but I do love
that movie and Gene Hackman is amazing
in it Oh everybody's amazing what was it
like being directed by your father
Scott it's scary
you don't know if I love it okay yeah
it's it's uh I mean it's like you know
it's it's in my dad's not he's not a
warm and fuzzy type of guy mm-hmm so you
don't wanna you don't wanna well you
know what it's okay we just beep it out
that's just fine yeah don't worry about
that
you don't want to screw that one up no
you don't want to screw it up you know
but it's I think it's good you know the
way he the way he sort of had his his
just you don't you know there's no
handout so like if if you are gonna come
and work with me sure I'm gonna make
sure everybody knows there's no handouts
yeah I bad I imagine so Scott Eastwood
here on the rich estion again before you
get to the brand you are you spent some
time in Hawaii but you were born
obviously in the Monterey Peninsula
yeah does that mean Raider 49er what are
you 49er okay 49er so this season has
got to be it it's it's looking pretty
good yes it is so far yeah it's looking
like I mean Jenna hands is a genius huh
well I mean it's been a while obviously
it's taken a couple years but so far so
good six and oh right now ances so who
was your your your quarterback growing
up would that be just trying to do in
your in my mind here would it be it well
it was it was both it was it was Joe
Montana and Steve Young right sure but I
think it it was sort of the end of
Montana's career and into Steve Young
sure you're right the sort of I was
watching as a young kid right and my dad
sort
a torn because he's he was born in
Oakland so he's sort of an Oakland and a
Niners fans he's kind of in between so I
think he's a little bit of a
flip-flopper I've seen him do that you
know you know and normally that's where
you call somebody out for being a fake
fan yeah but is it right now but but no
but but when it's Dirty Harry you know
now he can he can obviously you know he
run runs that town does but it's pretty
cool to see
so that means I'm you know I work with
Steve Mariucci so he's the coach of
probably a lot of those teams that you
were rude yeah yep those are the Terezin
and and and obviously Steve Young you
know yes yeah so tell me about this
brand of clothes I've got the Hat right
here it's called may here it's it's you
know it's pretty it's speaks for itself
I think it's it's made here in America
you know what the whole point of the
brand is to create products that
celebrate the American worker mm-hmm
it's not political at all it's for
everybody it's about celebrating your
neighbor or celebrating the people that
work in manufacturing and other people
that work in this country and we're
trying to just create cool stuff yeah
which that we're looking right now is
create a weather cycle products and
shirts and and this hat is pretty cool I
will absolutely wear it and people say
what what is it what party is Uncle Sam
coming home from with his his vest in
his bowtie being undone sounds like a
good party it does sound like a good
party
yeah and I'll and people can go to made
here brand.com
you know to purchase all this stuff made
entirely exclusively in American
factories it's good to see you Scott
Eastwood thanks for having no thanks for
coming on this show yeah
please come on and you know for your
next project or any of you certainly if
you're giving free stuff to give
somebody in in sports and television
sports television free stuff I mean
you're in I like a good idea you know
how to market this thing at Scott
Eastwood on both Twitter and Instagram
made here brand calm for all this great
gear we're back to set up the rest of
the week in a second toko anyway for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show